[Musique]
jean mcewen était le peintre de la
couleur et de la texture un grand
artiste canadien qui peignait avec ses
mains et ses doigts d'un peintre exploré
vraiment la surface du tableau la
couleur les textures il était un maître
dans l'art de peindre avec ses mains il
disait qu'il passait de la main à la
couleur donc et on dit même que on peut
voir ses empreintes digitales sur un
certain des tableaux
[Musique]
le musée des beaux-arts a voulu rendre
hommage à ceux montréal est un peu tombé
dans l'oubli depuis sa mort il ya 20 ans
alors qu'il était connu et apprécié par
le public et ses pairs de son vivant il
a été influencé par bord du à et était
aussi l'ami de jean paul riopelle
mais il n'a pas signé le manifeste du
refus global très rapidement et l'a
trouvé sa voie n'est plus ni moins et
les automatismes avait une peinture qui
était beaucoup plus gestuelle on sent le
juste dans la peinture ce que mais qu'il
ne voulait pas faire lui il voulait
vraiment explorer la surface du tableau
la couleur en tant que telle la texture
mais sans faire de gestes jean mcqueen
était membre de l'association des
artistes non figuratif de montréal il
excellait aussi dans l'art de
l'aquarelle et la poésie avec cette
série d'aquarelles illustré de poèmes
composés pour sa femme sa première
exposition s'est tenue en 1949 au musée
des beaux-arts de montréal
il a aussi exposé au brésil aux états
unis en angleterre et au japon et des
mêmes souvent moi je fais toujours le
même tableau et ils n'en étaient pas
gêné non plus parce que et sentait qu'il
y avait toujours quelque chose à
explorer à approfondir dans le type de
travail qu'il faisait un peintre fidèle
à ses convictions à son credo ni plus ni
moins un magnifique artiste à découvrir
ou à redécouvrir ici catherine françois
radio canada montréal